Que diriez vous d'un p'tit peu de sociologie ?
Aujourd'hui on est sur Social Interaction Trainer!
Oui j'ai pas dit bonjour, j'suis mal poli, et alors ?
C'est un jeu dans lequel nous sommes face des situations plus ou moins gênantes
et nous contrôlons uniquement les yeux de notre personnage  .Vous savez que les yeux en disent beaucoup sur le fond de notre pensée
cf. lie to me "- il a regardé a gauche ça veux dire qu'il cherche dans des souvenirs qui n'existent pas"
"- oui tu a raison mais pourquoi tu est aussi stylé"
"- parce que je suis le héros d'une série".
Bon on n'arrête ce monologue.
Bref on a beaucoup parlé, hein,
là on a failli faire une intro plus longue que MRLEV12, ça va pas du tout.
Donc on contôle les yeux du personnage comme ça et on va apprendre à faire face a ces situations de merde
Donc on contrôle les yeux du personnage comme ça et on va
apprendre à faire face à ces situations de merde.
"Utilise ton regard pour intéragir socialement
avec le caissier"
Bon il y a rien de gênant dans cette situation.
Elle nous parle ?
Heu, faut plus que j'la regarde là ?
Heu, je regardes les courses... Ouais, c'est ça !
Oh ! Et là, je la re-regarde vu qu'elle se remet à me parler.
*ting, comme pour le bruit des messages de téléphones*
*souffle longuement* Lie to me . Lie to me !
Urinoirs ! Ça c'est extrêmement gênant.
Utilise l'urinoir à coté !
c'est là que c'est dur.
Normalement quand tu vas aux toilettes,
il y a 3 urinoirs,
il y a un mec ici
et tu vas là
Quand c'est pas le cas c'est vrai que t'es un peu mal !
Mais la mec avec tes yeux, juste, tu regarde en bas, tu regardes, tu regardes juste...
Tu regardes juste, euh..., ton énorme tronc d'arbre !
Ne permetez pas à votre regard
de s'éloigner de votre tâche
Mais ma tache c'est ... c'est ça ?!
Ah non, il faut que je regarde lui ?
Oh il a regarder !
Il a regarder putain
Tu sais quoi je vais regarder lui j'men bas les couilles
regardez les parties intimes de quelqu'un d'autre
n'est pas encouragent
Bah sa va ça peut être que je suis surpris de cette chose imposante !
Si je regarde en l'air
Oh je tes vue ! Ahh
Regarde les parties intimes de l'autre un minimum. Incroyable traduction
Mais on fait jamais ça ! On regarde jamais celui du voisin !
Un peu mais pas trop ... Je repasse sur moi !
Un petit peu mais tout doux .... Je repasse sur moi !
Mais non ! Il faut
que je regarde un certain temps sinon
il le prend mal
1 , 2 , je repasse à moi
0.. Mais non ! 1, 2 je repasse à moi
1,2 la qu'il m'a regarder il a vu que j'étais entrain de regarder son truc !
Il est content et je crois que ça passe .
Voila c'est ça !
Il fallait qu'il me voit entrain de voir son penis !
En vrai, dans cette situation il y a embrouille.
"Et tu fais quoi ?!"
Moi j'suis du 93 hein
Deja  quand tu dis "93" c'est que tu viens pas du 93 .
Le transport ! Oh non me dis pas que c'est le coup de la jolie fille qui
tous les jours quand tu vas au travail c'est elle qui s'assoie à coté de toi
et qui dit ni son nom, ni son prénom, ni son age
mais tu connais ses mensurations
Mais tu n'est pas un pervers ...Lol
C'est parti !
Oh c'est ça je le savais !
Commence une conversation avec ta partenaire de transport
C'est certainement pas ... Pardon, pardon.
Elle a eu peur par ta tentative d'interaction
Oui, je comprends
Le mieux c'est de faire genre tu lis le livre !
Et la ça a marcher ! Elle s'est mise à me parler
Je me mais à lui parler .
Lie to me !
Pourquoi tu regardes en l'air ?
Tu es géné ?
devant cette situation ?
Le café
A c'est la même fille , c'est la fille du bus !
On a eu son numero et on la revoie le lendemain au café c'est incroyable.
Fait bonne impression pour ton 1er rendez-vous
Attend avant de commencer je me pose une question.
Est-ce que c'est pas comme le délire de l'urinoir ?
Est-ce qu'il faut pas qu'elle me voit en train de regarder son décolleté pour qu'elle se sente bien ?
Bon dans la vraie vie tu te prends une gifle mais le mec dans ce jeu il a pas connu beaucoup de filles.
Et il a pas connu beaucoup d'urinoirs non plus.
Bon on va voir, on va voir c'est parti.
Je te regarde pendant que tu me parles, oui
Oh oui regarde je suis poli !
Je regardes tes boobs... Oh pardon !
Pendant que je parle je regarde en l'air
comme toi, genre "oh je réffléchis"
"oh lala je te raconte ma journée d'hier"
Merde ça va pas x3
euh les boobs,
les boobs ? Tu as regardé dans le vent trop de fois
Ah merde ! Qu'est-ce qu'il faut que je fasse ?
Ah je peux loucher ! Elle me regarde quand je louche
elle tape une barre !
Est-ce que quelqu'un a déjà réussi à séduire une fille parce qu'il a louché ?
Ca m'intéresse énormément, n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer un mail
Ok ça part sur un parc.
C'est la même fille qu'on emmène à un deuxième rendez-vous ? oui !
Quoi de mieux que d'aller au parc ?
Hop, je regarde en l'air pendant que moi je parle
On... On le regarde dans les yeux, on le fixe dans les yeux !
On a pas peur de l'embrouille !
Putain vous avez vu ? Quand on le fixe pas dans les yeux elle en profite, elle elle se rince l'oeil hein !
Merde. -Vous avez réagi trop violemment la situation s'est aggravée-
Ah lui pour le coup c'est le vrai mec du 9-3
La règle des deux secondes elle est là
Je vais tenter un truc. Je vais faire n'importe quoi avec les yeux et peut-être que ça va passer.
Donc là je le fixe et dès que je vais me mettre à parler je vais loucher.
Voilà ! Qu'est-ce que tu vas faire ?!
What the fuck ?
Whaaaaaat ?!
Ne faites jamais ça !
Mais je croyais que c'était de la vraie sociologie putain.
Mais là le mec déjà il a envie de te maraves la gueule et ensuite
c'est sûr et certain il part avec ta copine !
Même tes parents ils adoptent ta copine ils veulent plus de toi !
Bon situation suivante. C'est la romance.
Qu'est-ce que la romance ?
Achète des préservatifs
Ca c'est affreux !
Bon petite technique, vous allez à un distributeur automatique
et vous mettez un foulard, plus une capuche,
plus un masque de ski, il fait très froid dehors en plus c'est crédible.
Mais si vous craquez et que vous allez au Monoprix du coin
On va regarder les préservatifs
*lit la phrase avec un accent anglais douteux*
Ne pas marmonner votre souffle. Ok
je sais pas ce que ça veut dire mais ça marche.
Alors je la regarde elle... *buzz* Voilà !
je l'ai rendu mal à l'aise
Normal. Je crois qu'il faut alterner super vite.
Oui... oui c'est bon c'est ça !
*voix off de femme* : Jean-Claude à la caisse pour les capotes more size.
Un entretien d'embauche
C'est ma première fois, c'est parti dépuçage en direct
faut le convaincre de te prendre
Il se passe quoi avec son oeil !?
Attends je vais pas travailler pour cet homme !
Ah non merde ! L'interview a grillé que tu dévisageais son oeil.
Tu ne seras pas recruté.
Ah merde, putain.
Attends, peut-être qu'il faut mettre son oeil droit ?
Si je louche,
tu me prends ou pas, c'est drôle ? Eh, ça m'a permis de me sortir de beaucoup de situations, méfis toi !
En fait je pense qu'il faut que je regarde à un endroit où je lui parle
mais faut que quand je reste à cet endroit lui ne me regarde pas.
Putain c'est interminable mec cet entretien !
Heureusement que j'en ai jamais fait....
L'interviewer a mal placé votre demande, vous ne serez pas recruté.
Bon tu sais quoi ? Je vais devenir youtubeur, voilà !
Les billets bientôt ils seront là !
Putain comment je vais expliquer ça à Clotilde ?
La femme de ma vie que j'ai rencontré dans le bus
Tant que ses parents on s'en bat les couilles.
Merde ! C'est mes parents ou ses parents ?
Ne sois pas trop gêné pendant ta rencontre avec ses parents.
C'est parti.
Bon la maman me parle, je la regarde
Ma copine parle je la regarde
Là on me parle je la regarde
Essaie de ne pas péter dans cette situation.
Vraiment ? Plus on avance dans cette vidéo plus la sociologie elle s'en va, comme ça,
elle atteint la stratosphère comme ça, elle tombe,
elle repart.
Et elle me dit que ma blague était nulle.
Faut peut-être loucher ?
Je vais loucher
non. Tout le monde a remarqué que tu fais des truc chelous.
Merde. Comment je fais pour
ne pas louffer mais pour ne pas paraître teubé ?
Peut-être faut mixer ?
C'est bon, fallait loucher quand tu changeais de regard.
Personne n'a grillé.
Fais bonne impression devant son père
Il fallait louffer, le con il adore ça !
On va bien s'entendre.
Fais bonne impression avec sa mère.
Ok.
J'ai un putain de chien qui me regarde
Je regarde la mère, je regarde le chien
Bon, j'ai rien compris mais ça a marché apparemment.
Ca c'est vrai dans la vrai vie,
il t'aime bien mais du c'est pas pourquoi.
Bravo vous êtes le bienvenue dans la belle famille.
Et on finit sur une bonne note.
Merci d'être venu au cours, n'oubliez pas demain page 34
faites les 6 exercices.
Et peut-être qu'un jour vous saurez lire sur les visages comme moi.
Tu regardes en haut à gauche, tu as oublié de liker la vidéo ? FDP.
Merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo, je vous aime.
Un peu d'amour, ça fait plaisir ?
N'oubliez pas d'aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu.
Et sinon là le mec de Lie to me il va venir vous casser les... les cheveux.
C'était cool ce petit jeu même si la moitié des situation c'était du bullshit
l'autre moitié c'est quand même assez vrai.
Mais j'ai quand même beaucoup aimé il y a un petit côté sociologique
qui me plaît énormément. Mais j'aurai aimé
que ce soit un peu plus sérieux.
La blague du prout par exemple
euh... mouaf... c'est minable.
*bruit de pet*
Est-ce que c'est pas un peu l'hopital qui se fout de la charité Squeezie ?
Qui a fait ça ? *bruit de pet*
Aller à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo, merci d'avoir regarder
Portez-vous bien, ciao tout le monde ! Peace !